I promise you [ __ ] an album you've
been patiently waiting now today is
finally present I took my time with the
[ __ ] I put my mind into every line cuz
when inside I'm trying to regret it
[ __ ] get overhyped and all they hits
ghosts I know that you um you're a huge
Eminem fan and yeah I think it's very
clear when you hear you're very heavily
influenced by Eminem just for me like
when I hear you I I get reminiscent like
like Rawkus records Eminem like sound
Bhama to you know Slim Shady LP [ __ ] I
got an oh man what are your thoughts on
the new album Marshall Mathers LP 200
fall I'm gonna say this like Eminem he's
to me he's the best rapper of all time
like he's really close to being the goat
yeah maybe to me he is yeah so like I
just I'm gonna love anything he does
regardless just you know I've just been
a fan I just really like him and him and
everything he does like but I'm more of
a fan of the older stuff just because
you know that's what that's what like 3
when you yeah really really drew me in
to him and you know I learned a lot of
stuff from just listening to his music
and you know watching eight-mile that
stuff like really inspired me so and now
you know now that I'm a rapper that I'm
like and I'm like a full-throttle
rapping out doing [ __ ] I got my career
and I'm like in the game it gives you a
whole new perspective on everything so
now it's almost like it's hard for me to
like a lot of things I just taught me to
even like myself at times because I'm so
judgmental but um so when I hear
everything's new stuff I'll still grow
to like it like I'm still gonna bump in
regards as a fan I was kind of
disappointed
because the title is marshallmatters oh
yes I mean I cannot I can understand how
people say that you know and it does
sound a little you know different from
the original marshmallows just
aesthetically I feel like the vibe a lot
of the girls singing on the hooks it's
like yeah yeah I know it almost they
don't yeah it has kind of a poppy feel
to it
oh yes it is it is different I think
that it's not like as like just to
please flow change to where like used to
flow just like really like water so now
I'm even says that you write robot they
are we're at but I've spilled all the
funnel energy so easy is aware of it but
it just sound it sounds a lot different
than what it used to and me as a rapper
now I I'm very judgmental on everything
so any rabbit I used to like I judge
them in the new ways I'm like I don't
know if I can like them but I was bumps
I still love no matter what if I met him
they'll be like oh but like I'll feel
you have anything you have an edit you
have never on their bed and it's crazy
maybe yeah when that happens yes I know
yeah and I would even want to if I met
him I don't want to meet him as no
rapper
just wanna meet him on some fan [ __ ]
yeah just even that as I would just like
to have a conversation with him not be
sad but like I don't care I don't want
to be like you'll need to collab man yo
do this again yeah I did not looking for
anything it is more of just like cuz I'm
all about like learning experiences and
I know he's been what I've been he's
been plays that I haven't made as far as
career-wise and all that I showed you
like even what the flood like how does
it what is it like like you said I've
already realistic and he's on another
that's why I don't know yeah so I'm like
I already feel like like I already fit
he's another youniverse
I'm like I'm gonna nother planet when
you just arrived for you guys no you got
me my mother's here
he's another whole [ __ ] universe and
[ __ ]
so it's just like I would just like
talking to be like yeah what the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] like how do you feel
what is it done to your life like what
are you what are the things that you
loved about it things that you might
have regretted you would have done
differently to or you wish you could
have like it's interesting not an any
famous person and I would like to ask
those questions degree of the game for
that long oh yeah because you know it
because it helps me as well and it's
just interesting to know that he's a
[ __ ] horrible wife rapper he's wack
period no way around it he is whack in
the dick in the dictionary whack it
again yes say this like Emma Davies
these to me he's the best rapper of all
time